all right thank you very much for coming
to the stop my name is Luis I work in my
heritage and today I'll be telling you
guys about some of our work with like
genomic predictions and some of our
techniques so there's two main goals for
this talk the first one is to get you
guys excited about doing machine
learning or deep learning in genomics
and there is many reasons to be excited
about that like the first one is the
sort of like I think it's like a
uniquely challenging data scale so like
so for each example you might have like
tens of millions of features and they
are not sort of like particularly like
sparse which creates like a lot of
challenges another reason to be excited
about it is that at least in my opinion
is sort of like very like early days in
doing machine learning deep learning
genomics and you have like the
opportunity to really develop techniques
which are tailored for genomics and the
third reason which draw that should be
like the chief reason it's actually like
the potential to improve like people's
lives by allowing them like to
understand themselves better and the
secondary go for the stone is to
describe like some of our approach but
that's really like the first one is
mostly to get like an overview or if you
so the stock would happen in three parts
in the first part we'll be talking about
heritability and genomic predictions and
why like we should care about them in
the second part who give like a brief
introduction to DNA as well as the data
format and in the third part will be
describing our methods so before we
start I'll give a brief introduction to
my heritage as well so my heritage is
essentially a genealogy company which
means that like a year ago it focused on
being like a platform on which you can
save and further research or family
history so like a lot of people might
have used it when they were doing like I
put that terrarium or something like
that and this is sort of like a snapshot
of the company right now we are over 400
people over 500,000 like paying
subscribers over 90 million users and
over 8 billion historical records so
this historical records they can be like
user inputted data so for example like
you might put your the birth
later the birth location of your
great-grandparents or something like
that as well as other kinds of
historical records from different
databases so and these historical
records they are updated like frequently
and there's always like new additions so
like one example that was that it like
in January it's all these different
collections so like different like
newspapers and one we took and finding
information about your family as well as
like different kinds of applications so
one particular interesting one that was
added in January was all the
applications for immigration to British
Palestine within a period of years
before independence so one of the
records over there is there like this
young man who by demos collection
burski and that was like its application
so you guys can also like find relevant
information well you know you're under
sentence in this or in other databases
and since serve DNA has a lot to do with
your heritage about one year ago my
heritage started doing DNA tests and it
was then the science team which ran part
two as founder and we're doing like
several things one is a part of like the
ethnicity estimate that you get as it's
part of your it's one of the products so
with that you can start like understand
like what fraction of your DNA comes
from like which of the supported so we
have like 42 available right now and the
guy did actually develop most of it is
sitting there if you guys have any
specific questions another thing is
genetic matches which I don't have a
snapshot for here now but that you can
find which people that have like consent
and they're very interested in finding
genetic matches for which you share a
DNA so for example you can go and find
sort of like some like long-lost sibling
as well as like a really distant
relative and this is one example of the
ethnicity estimate going back and the
third goal of the science team is to do
like long term like research that
doesn't have to have specific product
utility so like in the same sense it
just based on your DNA you can
understand a lot about your like
ethnicity so to say which says a lot
about like where your family likely has
been in the
like several hundred years like what
else can we say so I can we predict
other types of trades so it is sort of
like in this like research context that
the stock fits all right so let's talk
about a heritability and genomic
predictions now so let's start with with
an example so let's say we have Frank
and Molly okay and I have two kids their
own Ben and Lisa all right so let's say
that Frank is 185 Molly is 175 and Frank
has a high LDL or like the bad
cholesterol and Molly has like normal
cholesterol now like we can ask like a
few questions so like what do you guys
think like do you think that there is
more than 50% chance that their son Ben
will be over like 190 tall like what
what do you guys think no okay what
about the chance that Lisa will have
like high LDL cholesterol the like why
is it hard to make like to ask like
these questions about like genomic
predictions like I think it's fairly
obvious but like what why is it hard
right they're very complex right and
they're not also that uniquely like
genetic right like the fact that Frank
has a high cholesterol is not uniquely a
product of his of his DNA but it's also
of like all kinds of other like
environmental things right so this and
that sort of like the like we want to
understand like what percent of like the
variance in a specific trait has to do
with your DNA and how much of it has to
do with the environment all right and
this is like perfectly explained in the
following like cartoon right which this
lady's like weight problem is partly
genetic and partly a Boston cream pie
and that's so the questions are like how
heritable are these traits in a
quantitative sense so like one like big
challenge like health can you even like
measure like heritability right like if
you want to understand like the effect
of something you have to be able to
control for like all the other things
right so how there's like so many things
that are like car to like control for
right when you want to make these kinds
of comparisons like so one of it is sort
of like the environment and the and your
nutrition right this is definitely like
effects all kinds of things your family
your income and like health care right
like how much like accessibility to
health care you have as well as like
prenatal effects or like what were your
conditions like during like pregnancy
right like what's your mother ate like
plays a big role in these things or like
all kinds of other conditions so like do
you guys have any ideas for how to try
to control for like all of these things
together I I can say that I definitely
did not and I was quite puzzled by yeah
like this before
hmm the question is I can you try to
come up with an experiment that would
control for like all these different
types of conditions to try to understand
how heritable the specific trait is to
instead is is the answer so these have
been done already like for like decades
and what you do is that you compare
perfect twins right those are twins that
share a hundred percent of their genes
against regular twins which are like
genetically they're pretty much like
siblings they compare like regular
siblings they share only 50% of their
genes and what you do is that let's say
for example for height you can compare
like the
like the like correlation between
perfect twins right we're surely the
same environment but a hundred percent
of their genes and you can compare that
with the correlation with regular twins
so like let's say that you have sort of
like like a point seven correlation
among perfect twins but you have a point
four correlation among regulatory so
this means that there is a genetic
component to this trait whenever there
is this discrepancy and I'm perfectly
skipping a few details here but it's
like yeah this controls for like family
income health care prenatal effects as
well as like environmental nutrition
because you know unless something goes
like Rome like your twins should be
eating the same thing it's from there
and skipping a few details again the
with that kind of statistic you can come
up with these these estimates for like
the variance explained by genetics for
all these different traits alright so
these are all from from twist twin or
like related studies and this is sort of
like how much of the specific trait is
due to genetics so like so for some of
these it's not surprising that genetics
plays a big role such as like height or
like maybe like heart disease but for
some other ones III was like quite
surprise so for example for like
schizophrenia and depression I I think
out of like your ignorance I used to
think that they were sort of like
entirely like environmental traits in
the sense that like what you went
through like in life somehow like made
you more or less likely to develop these
conditions but it's actually they have a
very strong genetic component to them
and just to give you like a sense of
like what like these numbers means so
for like schizophrenia which is like a
really like horrible like disease like
it I think less than like 0.5% of the
general population has it but if you
have a perfect twin and that twin has it
that I think raises your chances of
having schizophrenic three plus percent
right so like it has a very strong
genetic component all right so we have
that some traits are heritable and
there's also in the following effect
which
like names like the missing heritability
which is the fact that most algorithms
they have not explained that much
variance right so for example like for
breast cancer let's say that 35% of it
should be explained by genetics so that
means that ideally there is some
algorithm out there which can predict
your likelihood to have breast cancer
and achieve like that upper bound on
accuracy which is dictated by the 35%
and the fact is that for like the vast
majority of traits we are like very far
from that so this is like the missing
heritability like issue and the hope is
that like big data and all kinds of
techniques can sort of a close that gap
and for this talk we'll be talking about
like height prediction because that's
something at like at our comparing like
we happen to have like relatively like
large data set for with like not a lot
of noise so we'll be talking about lis
estimating height all right so like but
I guess like first we should ask
ourselves like why should we care to
predict these traits at all so one
reason is that people can take proactive
action right so I think a really good
example for this is I think you guys
probably can't read but this is a
hundred in the jelly's op-ed in the New
York Times in 2013 in which she she
wanted to describe like her thought
process for why she decided to to do a
mastectomy which means like a breast
removal so she was diagnosed with eighty
seven percent chance of developing
breast cancer that was like partly
genetic and partly from family history
and what this allowed her to do is to
make a decision to like remove her
breasts which like drastically
they created like your chance of breast
cancers this is one example of proactive
actually people can take a second one is
a personalized medicine so if like a
drug manufacturer can understand like
which people are more or less likely
based on genetics to develop to respond
well to specific drug they can like
essentially give like better medicine
and this is like very like real and this
would be really in the future and the
third more far-fetched
or at least for now it's a bit more
futuristic is CRISPR which is a
technique for genome editing
so this was a thing developed like in
the relatively recent past and what this
allows to do is to just edit specific
letters in your DNA so this wasn't the
possibility like at all before and it
has already like been done in animals so
like one example of this is a crazy that
sounds is this dog which was genetically
made to look like a lion alright and
this is a joke this is actually from
Turin if you guys want to you can buy
this in a costume for your dog there
alright but this is not a joke this is a
dog that was genetically changed in his
like muscled rings so to say to develop
a lot of muscles right so I'm I think I
don't hear a lot of laughs now and yeah
this is like relatively scary and
dangerous and that's why it hasn't been
done in humans yet at a great extent but
it will very likely be a possibility in
the future
so these are like a few reasons why
genomic predictions are important I hope
I convinced you that like genetic
predictions are important so like nah
let's keep like a brief introduction to
DNA as well as like the data formats so
essentially like DNA can be seen as a
really long array of letters where the
letters are a cg or T that are like the
alphabet of genetics and it just happens
that your DNA is split in like 23
chromosomes one of which you get from
your dad and one of which you get from
your mom and they're like relative sizes
or something like this and sort of like
and the it will comes or like in this
format and just like some terminology
here so like when we refer to a snip
that's a feature it's actually like in
the model like so for example here in
this like chromosome we can say that
like the disposition in this specific
chromosome that's a snip okay and the
value of that feature is an illegal
right so that's that's the temperature
so the points are like C is a feature
and a little bit are like the value of
that feature as far as the model is
concerned and each of these can be like
hundreds of millions of letters long and
when you add them all the chromosomes
together it's something on the order of
like 3 billion features right which is
quite hard
just to give you like a computer science
II perspective can be hundreds of
millions of letters long and if you try
to put like let's say it was like one
bit per for a letter this would be
something on your like a gigabyte for a
person right which is a which is quite a
lot and but the points are like this spy
this is not like all bad news and like
despite over differences in like color
and shapes it actually turns out that
over that we are like more than 99% the
same so if you take like any like two
people over like 99 percent of their
snakes will be the same so there isn't
like all that much like difference among
us which means that we only need to
sample a small fraction of your genome
so so we actually we only sample
something on the order of like a million
like snips and and on top of that there
is like some like data like enrichment
techniques that like at the end of that
you might have something yard of like
tens of millions of features per person
which is still like quite challenging
right so you guys like quickly about
like this or like lab work I actually
don't understand it like too well so
we'll go fast so the way it works that
you order keep at home and then use like
swab your like cheek for like cheek
cells and you put it back in the tube
you send it to the lab at that point
it's like extracted and like place on a
chip and at this points are like some
magic that I don't understand happens
essentially like the fluorescence
pattern of that chip
you can like read data from it so
essentially like let's say that this
dark spot here it might that maps into a
specific value of that snake okay and
like the light green will map into a
different value and at the end what you
have is an umpire matrix if you guys
want where like each row is like one
person and the numbers they would be
like zero one or two and I won't go into
the details so much but essentially like
it's if you could be a zero if both of
your chromosomes for that position they
have the most common
ladder at that position right so let's
say that like this versus this for a
specific position you have an A and a is
the most common letter in that position
for the general population then we'll
have a zero and if you have like a C
therefore for both parents then you have
a two which is like dinner and if you
have like one A and one C you have a one
so if you like those are less couple of
minutes the important thing to
understand is just that essentially like
you summarize your DNA data as this
longer array of zero ones and twos all
right any questions here you also know
if it's an AC or you just have the
indication if it's matching the in
general population or not but you gotta
have the actual value we also have the
actual bed yeah so I skipped that part
but but you also have the actual value
for now only snips what's up you've
assured it to places like two features
for the same for two persons no sorry
the same place in the vector two people
would mean the same feature like how can
you show that that's how like these
chips are made essentially so like if
they read the same thing then they will
have the same feature there's like some
amount of like genotyping error with
some like small probability but in
general like you can expect them to be
the same thing so all right so that's
the data format and a lot of know
describe like your methods alright so in
order to like understand like really
like any type of like genetic like
models like it's really important to
understand like something called like
linkage disequilibrium
so like linkage is libram like it
provides like many challenges like the
first one is pronunciation so we'll call
it LD from now on
and the second one is that it's what it
means essentially is that nearby like
snips they tend to be inherited together
which leads to really large blocks of
correlated features okay so the
essentially like if two snips are nearby
together like physically they tend to be
to being very high correlation to each
other so you might this is an example of
a like a correlation matrix let's say
you have like 1,000 or second of snips
okay and so this is like a thousand by
thousand matrix the correlation matrix
and so you might think that the
correlation matrix might look something
like this in which like the off diagonal
entries they are like some positive
number that's a fine guess but in
reality looks more like this
so this is an actual example all right
so what happens is that you have like
these blocks so for example you have
this X square in the correlation matrix
and then sort of like sharp like fall
and then sort of like a new X square so
essentially like you have these like
blocks of snips that are in high
correlation and then sort of like boom
and a new block of still very high
correlation so this is actually probably
not the best example since the
population for this is like relatively
like hetero genius but for like more
homogeneous population this would look
much more like actual blocks and I think
like LD is probably like the most
mapping like the most distinctive
feature like in genetic data and it's
important to understand so like some
common solutions in the literature for
how that yeah this one is just a great
moving correlated features so you can
just like survey go in blocks and then
once this is something which is ignored
in correlation to the previous ones you
just like include that in your feature
set another one which has been done more
recently is using like la so against
like a specific target function to let
you know supervised way like specify
your data and there's like a couple of
issues with with MIT defer but the
project the most important one is that
you end up like losing a lot of
information so in the first one like
it's obvious like while you're losing a
lot of information but even in the
second
against the target function you you're
just like picking like slips that were
like activated like in lasso and the
other ones are not basically like not
really included at all right so who try
to tackle this in a in a different way
that doesn't lose that information and
yes correlation consistent between
samples like you always get the same
snippet in everyone or is just like
these tons within like a homogeneous
population it's fairly consistent yeah
but if you have like very different
populations then it will be consistent
yeah we'll use something like location
sensitive hashing good because it seems
that if the correlations with a distance
and location sensitive hashing codes we
haven't tried it so so how do we handle
it leaked so it wasn't like common like
tool like new machine learning to do
dimensionality like reduction and to
remove correlated T transistors are like
blindly perhaps like apply like PCA so
like as a first step in your algorithm
you can apply PCA and that will give you
like a set of uncorrelated features all
right and so the fact the point earlier
PC helps you create like independent
feature so we might think something can
we use it in order to like to summarize
that lb structure into a much lower
dimensional space so that's what we do
and so let's look at like an example of
how PCA actually like X on on such data
so this is a synthetic example
all right off like an idealized like
correlation matrix in like perfect
LD so we have here like this is 300 by
300 and we have like 6 LD blocks each of
like 50 snips H okay and so the
correlation matrix will look something
like this and let's so before we talk
about what you see we do it's just like
quickly like recap what we see does in a
nutshell so if you have like a data
matrix X of like n by P so like an
example then P features and the target
number of components to which you want
to
that's number of features you want again
if they can find the P by K matrix we'll
call it V such that when you
apply v2x it maximizes variance so it's
sort of like fine it's a finding a
matrix to which you can multiply your
data matrix such that the smaller and
the key here of course is that K should
be like much less than P in order to
dimensional reduction and that will like
preserve the most information okay and V
it's got like the matrix are like
principle directions and they happen to
be the right similar vector isn't for X
but it's not important for us so let's
so this is like one example like we did
on a scalar because the data scale is
fine here and so this is actually the
matrix V okay
after computing pieces that's the matrix
of components which you can multiply
your data matrix ax so one know sort of
like feature of this is that like it
clearly captures like the block
structure in the data right like it
clearly like understands that this data
comes in like a lot of blocks correlated
features and second things are like you
can try to interpret it as so like the
third one over there is just a highlight
thing like the large values would say so
like maybe maybe like that first
principle direction here so these two
rows
it looks like it's capturing some kind
of summary of what's going on in this
last LD block here right make if you
guys a moment to try to digest that let
me know if there's any questions it's a
campaign there normal distribution
that's not necessary for yelling that's
not an like maybe you can prove
something extra if the data comes
normally distributed but it's time in
general so this is an example of
applying like PC on the real data that
we had before with a real LD and you
know there is like a lot more like noise
over here but again you can see there
like that's first principle direction
there it's also like somehow like
capturing the sort like some kind of
summary of that one
the block so nobody's like they say is a
good place to start if you want to
summarize your data and it comes in this
or like you know matrix multiplication
format which is like very handy if you
wanted like deep learning right and
that's what what we're going to do right
so summaries like PCA helps you tell me
because it captures a block structure
data and it's somehow like summarizes
the information that's in these pelvic
blocks okay all right so let's talk
about our technique so what we'll do is
that will be the two layer Network which
is like s standard something like this
okay so we have like the 1,000
furthermore like we'll do this we do
like one different model for different
consecutive blocks of a thousand steps
okay so we'll take like a thousand
consecutive snips and we'll move the
ball a model on that so we have like
1,000 sixes features and then the output
layer will try to predict height all
right so we make some extended choices
here like we're using a really what
operations and initialization and
non-standard thing that we do here it is
that we compute the PCs and then we use
that PC matrix V to initiate to
initialize the first layer in the
networks so instead of letting a one be
initialized like randomly I sort of like
it's typically done we actually like
force it to start with the values of
that matrix right which are like the
singular the right singular vectors of
the data matrix so what this is doing is
essentially like because we know I
priority the data will have this LD
structure it's essentially like forcing
the network to start by already knowing
this information about the LD blocks
right there's no reason to let it get
lost and wild trying to capture that we
can just like force it to start with
that and and then serve like during the
optimization it can learn sort of like
if a specific LD block is not relevant
for that trait C to learn like to down
weight that and if specific snip in
another LD block for example it's
particularly relevant it will learn to
update that so it's actually like it's
warm
during the network with the LD structure
and then like letting it sort of like
take it from there
and just like a couple of nodes here
like on some try Cecily we tried like
with different like depths as well and
like to work fine but also like we don't
really a priority expect to have like a
very complex normally the interaction so
we like to is I could find choice for
this the point here is not to try to
capture some really like exquisite
interactions here because they don't
happen too much as far as I know in
biology and another the choice for like
doing this in blocks of consecutive
snips versus trying to do it on the
whole thing
what is that also like you a priority
don't expect to have like really like
for interactions with different snips
okay so like we expect like most of
these interactions to be fairly local
and this is like one of the things we've
been trying it seems to be working well
but like we will be trying like a lot of
different iterations of this as well
alright so the results is that like
preliminary experiments have shown that
it's like outperforming like linear
models okay with these other types of
future selections that we talked about
and it's they were like we still need to
do some extra work to make the
performance numbers are comparable to
other things because it depends on like
the number of samples that depend on the
specific populations that you're doing
this with so will be you know we'll be
doing this like in a publication later
we saw the actually the performance
details the point is more like to give
you guys like a taste of the sorts of
approaches we've been doing here I
didn't ask if you guys have any
questions about the setup here
so the early they are the heights of
people so we just for completeness we
don't use the actual heights we use sort
of like the z-scores of the height
condition like on gender and it's nice
cities and things like that so some
transformation of people's Heights and
that's what we actually try to yeah so
essentially like the initialization that
we are making for the first layer is of
the values of the you know that PC
matrix and what happens essentially like
that maybe like that first component
over there it's like like the first
feature in the second layer like would
be some kind of summary of this so like
when I say it's working on blocks it's a
I think actually I seen something else
to just realize you're talking about
like the 1000 steps yeah so by like
block I mean that would create a
different model set up like 1000
consecutive steps that's what I mean
sorry
like maybe you have like 6 different
models or something like that it's so it
would be like if let's say our feature
set has like 1 million features then
this will be like 1000 different models
and how do like average over them
yeah so like we're still like trying
different things but I think right now
the latest thing a tribe was just doing
like lasso and on the predictions of the
of the of them or just averaging or
something
we're doing like mean squared error of
the of the z-scores yeah very good
question in like will first simplicity
we did not have like sort of like
different intercept we just have like
disjoint sets of snips which is like
losing a lot of information so low it's
something we're trying to future zone
increase could you say that again please
some sort of Hitler well I think like
the increasing like the number of layers
at least I can experiments we try didn't
really help too much because we April
don't really expect to have like these
like really complex interactions but
that's something like we'll try again in
the future again thanks are like the
onus point is that in the beginning this
makes it a lot easier to do because of
the data scale and the second point is
that again we don't expect to have serve
like these like really like for
interactions with different parts of the
chromosome so like if we can capture
things locally first at least this will
capture like most of the of the
information but when you say like this
feature is watching each other if I can
well like one was for a simplicity of
trying this like at first okay and I
think we'll be trying also eight with
different like instead of one K but
something like more or less but the
point is like if you know a priori that
like it's very unlikely that like some
really far away snips who have any
meaningful interaction then you know
maybe you won't be losing too much
information in this can train maybe this
will be able to like converge more
quickly yeah
pura see that you get a certain question
to you try is one can become you're not
and he's here to try other lands walk
and change dramatically at all accuracy
of their yeah so the the 1k here is a
fairly arbitrary it's arbitrary in this
sense that like there's no great reason
that I like 1k over like 2k we actually
haven't tried too much but like the
point is sort of like that the beginning
and the end of that 1k they will like be
like very uncorrelated so we wanted to
make sure like the LD blocks will be
that we have like several like lb blocks
in there and for the first question like
we've been comparing essentially
comparing against against another like
paper that came out recently to predict
height and it what it does essentially
like I proves the values first by
p-value and then it does lasso so I try
to compare it with that but the the
numbers right now like I'm having hard
time comparing them because the data
sets they are very different sizes so if
it's okay like a way to like actually
like say I don't I want to make sure
that I am NOT saying in the difference
in performance it's more like 20% if
it's not
the again just a it was 70 would be like
pretty much the whole things like the
data set that we're doing here actually
has something like 20,000 people only
all right so with 20,000 people there is
like no I hope of getting like that much
accuracy so it's closer to 10 than to
270 and but with like much larger data
so like actually in that lots of paper
they show the difference in performance
like geyser increases data sent so like
they had something like 15 are square of
0.15 with 20,000 people but with 500,000
people they had of like 0.45 or
something like that so it changes a lot
and we want to make sure the numbers are
comparable yeah well more features
yeah we we normalized yeah we normalize
the features before doing you know
that's the scoring we just do I think
the scale I don't ever exactly like what
is the latest thing but I think it's
just - maybe we just Center them I can't
remember exactly right now engine to use
a sample of your data not to use the
data and if it's some concern why people
will upload new DNA data to you because
you are ready and that the model that
works on the sample area
I'm not sure Granderson okay so do you
the sample of football user for full
data set to train this yes we well like
so we have so like this data is coming
from people that volunteer to
participate in the study and they give
the datasets a lot of data you're right
yeah so next now is that you have a
model then there's no need to collect
more data from people because
it's a lot data that's already
generalized or maybe the whole
population oh well like this is like one
of the you know the projects that we are
doing like there's like other things
that people are trying and like and
frankly this is like the most this is
not part of like the product right at
all so like so like we can for destiny
city estimates for example it's always
helpful to have like like more like high
quality data to be able to always keep
improving the models but for this
specifically something a side project no
all right so I've done a lot of time so
let me jump to the conclusion so there's
a couple of other challenges like one is
that right now like I'm fortunate like
most genetic data sets they have like
vastly more like basically people of
European descent than anything else and
so if you train a model with that it
will tend to do well for those people
but not necessarily and likely not at
all for other people so one challenge is
sort of like to ensure that like
whatever you're doing for people that
are actually like doing this in
affecting people's lives to ensure that
it works for like that in an inclusive
way a second goal is to make these
models more interpretable to understand
actual like mechanisms behind these
traits and so I hope I got you guys are
excited about like doing machine
learning genetics and happy to talk more
if you were to get started there is a
few of these datasets which you can
apply for or like open tip you can just
get and or even better you should just
like be in touch if you want to learn
more or if you have any other questions
so thank you very much
[Applause]